a big thank you to youtube for
transforming this amazing space for
hosting this super Funland and for Katy
Perry through an ethereal hit the desert
party for her fans and we need to talk
about the best things that happen inside
because I was there and I have the deets
and guess what I got interviews with the
two lucky fans who got tattoos with Katy
Perry yes this happened I got a time
that she tattooed with Katy Perry wholly
unexpected really didn't think I was
going to win
tonight was the best day of my life
there was also a fire alarm wait for it
a new music video a QA and a newfound
love for KP let's unpack everything we
are here to premiere the video first
things first is the new song we heard it
never really over produced by Zedd
it's a buff I love it it's great and
here's what it means to Katy it's really
just a song about like the choices we
have in life you know to take steps
forward or backwards and how your mind
is extremely powerful and how you know
if you don't take those steps forwards
even as hard as they may be you can take
a step backwards into a loop that you
don't love but you know so it's kind of
about that and also the it's about like
it's about the acceptance and the union
is about acceptance in light and dark so
you can't ever get rid of the dark but
you can accept that maybe it was a
lesson for you to that's right now the
video feels like a Joshua Tree fever
dream yeah you're gonna see it at
midnight on Friday so I'm not gonna
delve into like specific spoilers about
the video but it's something like this
clip from 40 year old virgin
wherever young age of aquarius you know
new-age esoteric california healing
hippy and medicinal all those keywords
plant-based see I wasn't getting it's a
new chapter for Katie but as for the
album and Beyond she kind of made it
seem like she's really gonna go with the
flow this time the time we live in I
think it there are less rules about how
you have to release music and what we're
finding is that people just want music
out you know if they don't necessarily
need it in a long format they don't
necessarily have the time and you know
we'd like to do that and just put music
out and if there is a if there is a
reaction like a good reaction or a
desire for more there could be more I
don't know if this feat will continue or
if there'll be another thing or you know
there's lot there's lots there are a lot
more are chapters obviously to share but
yes I really believe in symbolism and I
believe in you find me your home
painting
this music at this visual you know hide
on that I can tell you kind of like the
seed of the personal story about it but
I want to hear what it means to you
and the fire alarm okay this is gonna be
a little annoying brace yourselves
but a fire alarm derail the Q&A don't
worry there wasn't really a fire okay
the fan tattoos on site Katie had a
tattoo bus to get actual half-heart
tattoos that say miss and you I think
she is the miss and the fan gets for you
with two lucky winners and I'm sorry the
fire alarm is still going off during
these clips we're gonna tattoo together
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and those two are going to get the
tattoo with me the contest winners were
named Cathy and Matt and this is Cathy's
third Katy Perry inspired tattoo and
Matt traveled all the way from Brazil
[Music]
[Applause]
my first one I thought it was going to
hurt so much but actually is a good
thing we talked about my feet general
it's awesome because Katie always wants
to bring her fans close so she asked
about my life and we asked about her
life
which is so cutie and she oh she always
scared some so much about things it
means so much the most to go back to
work tomorrow and act like nothing ever
happens but the last thing I want to
talk about before we go
is how Katy interacted with her fans in
general at this event
those two fans that were on the bus
getting the tattoos Katy wasn't there
for 10 15 20 minutes 30 minutes even she
spent well over an hour on that bus with
those two fans just talking about life
just chit-chatting and then afterwards a
few more fans got tattoos and she kind
of like would go in and check on them
and then came outside and would take
pictures with everybody and people were
kind of like crowding her for a minute
and she was like don't worry guys every
single person here is going to feel
appreciated and I'm going to take a
photo with you and I'm gonna talk to you
I mean it always blows me away to see
things like that newfound respect for
you Katy she's humble down-to-earth
person
I met her a couple times back then and
surprisingly she remembers me it is
crazy I totally remember you definitely
mad as I'm like oh my gosh like out of
the whole movie with Matt or
it's shocking she's so itself meeting
this song is called never really over
and with that I truly believe that what
we have won't ever ever really do
[Applause]
[Music]